[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم
فيه الان تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من غازي عنتاب في
تركيا حيث تستمر اعمال الانقاذ والاغاثه
والايواء في مناطق مختلفه من جنوبي البلاد
في اليوم الثاني عشر بعد الزلزال الذي عصف
بعشر ولايات تركيا
هذه الصور هذه المره تاتينا من اعزاز
بريفي حلب الشمالي بينما تتواصلوا اعمال
الاغاثه ورفع الانقاض في اليوم الثاني عشر
من الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوبي تركيا وشمال
سوريا
وفي ميونخ
والجنوب المانيا انطلقت اعماله مؤتمر
ميونخ للامن في دوره هيمنه عليها موضوع
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قبل نحو عام
وضروره الاستمرار في تقديم الدعم العسكري
ومن العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن جاء اعلان
من القياس الامريكيه الوسطى بمقتل قيادي
بارز في تنظيم الدوله يدعى حمزه الحمصي في
غاره مشتركه في سوريا مع ما تعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه مساء امس الخميس اصيب
فيها ايضا اربعه جنود امريكيه
وفي مواضيع الحصائد لهذه الليله
برنامج الجزيره الاستقصائيه ما خفي اعظم
يعرض وثائق مسربه تكشف تورط قيادات امنيه
تونسيه في اداره عمليات مسلحه في البلاد
برلماني تونسي يؤكد ان القاده الامنيين لا
يزالون طلقاء ويقدمون المشوره لفريق قيس
سعيد
وتسجيلات صوتيه لنقابي امني مرتبط بقضيه
تسفير المقاتلين للخارج المثاره ضد
معارضين ترصد حديثهم مع شخصيه تعمل لصالح
النظام السوري
بعد 12 يوما على الكارثه
في تركيا تواصل العثور على ناجين تحت
الانقاد وعدد قتل الزلزال يقترب من اربعين
الفا جهود تتسارع لاغاثه مئات الالاف من
المنكوبين في مناطق تضررت المباني فيها
جزئيا او كليا
المشهد السوري في المناطق المنكوبه
بالزلزال تعثر ايواء المنكوبين وتقارير عن
نزوح اكثر من 55 الف شخص في شمال البلاد
وبعد حديث عن تهديد وكالات امميه لمنظمات
انسانيه سوريه اتهمت الامم المتحده
بالتقصير نائب المتحدث باسم غوتيرس ينفي
للجزيره اي ضغوط ويقول ان الامم المتحده
تحرص على عدم توظيف اي طرف للمساعدات
حرب اوكرانيا تهيمن على مؤتمر ميونخ للامن
خوخم
للخلفاء ارسلوا دباباتكم لاوكرانيا
يقول ان الوقت الان ليس للحوار
يحط قاده العالم على تسريع تسليم الدعم
العسكري وزير خارجيه استونيا يقول للجزيره
ان وجود قوات النيتو ضمانه في وجه موسكو
وروسيا تقول ان مشاركه دول النيتو في
الصراع بلغت مراحلها القصوى
بينما قال
79% انها بالاحرى محاوله لاحكام السيطره
على السلطه كما يقول معارض الرئيس
هذا سؤال سيبقى كالعاده مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا
على الشاشه لقاء على المنصات الرقميه
يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
قمه افريقيه في اديس ابابا او 14 نزاعا
نشطا تؤرق القاره
[موسيقى]
تونس الايادي الخفيه عنوان تحقيق ما خفي
اعظم الجديد فالبلد يعيش اليوم استقطابا
حادا على وقع اتهامات للرئيس التونسي قيس
سعيد بتوظيف القضاء لتصفيه حسابات سياسيه
مع معارضيه وفتح ملفات ضدهم كان ابرزها
ملف التسفير الذي طاولت التحقيقات فيه
قيادات في المعارضه ونشطاء ورجال اعمال
لاتهامهم بتسهيل سفر شبان تونسيين لمناطق
التوتر في كل من سوريا وليبيا وغيرهما
احد الشهود الرئيسيين في هذه القضيه والذي
فتح له الهواء عبر وسائل اعلام محليه
وخارجيه هو عصام الدردوري هو واحد من اكثر
الرجال الامن غموضا وجدلا في تونس رجل
الامن ورئيس منظمه الامن والمواطن عصام
الدردوري ليست فقط سهلت عمليه تصوير
الشباب الى بؤره التوتر
اعظم تسريبات تكشف ان الدردوري الشاهد في
قضيه التزفير متورط في تسفير وتسريب خطير
هيا من رجال المقاومه الاسلاميه في سوريا
تسجيلات صوتيه عرضها التحقيق كشفت مراسلات
بين عصام الدردوري وشخص لبناني يدعى محمد
علي اسماعيل يعمل لصالح النظام السوري
صديقنا الذي جلسنا معه في احدى المناسبات
يعني المستشار الحكومي هو في ديوان
الطائره المدني والمطارات وعلاقات يعني
ممكن يوصلنا في هذه السياق تكشف التسريبات
انخراط الدردور في تاجير طائرات تونسيه
بطرق غير رسميه والاخطر وتسرب معلومات
امنيه حساسه لمحمد علي اسماعيل تتضمن صورا
واسماء عناصر اختراق جن الامن التونسي
خارج الحدود بالنسبه للقرص المضغوط اللي
فيه صور متاع العناصر الغامقه بالاختراق
والادرب في الوحدات الامنيه اطلعت عليهم
الصور كلهم موجودين مرجلين عندك والتسجيل
شغال ماشي الدبدوري بدا انه اداه ضمن
منظومه ارتبطت بملفات عديده مثيره في تونس
حيث برزت من الرجل في قضيه اتهامه بتجنيد
فتاه لاسقاط قاض تونسي ممن اشرف على
التحقيق في احداث امنيه مثيره اهمها حادثه
التي وقعت في شهر مايو ايار عام 2016 وحصل
ما خفي اعظم على ملف وثائق التحقيق فيها
فالعمليه التي قدمت للمجتمع التونسي
باعتبارها اكتشافا لمجموعه من المسلحين
المتطرفين واحباطا لمساعيهم نحو تنفيذ
عمليات مسلحه في البلاد اسفرت عن قتل
اثنين من المسلحين واعتقال عدد اخر
ومصادره اسلحه وذخائر حسب الروايه الر
لكنها لم تكن في الحقيقه بحسب وثائق
التحقيقات سوى عمليه مفبركه بايدي قاده في
جهاز الحرس الوطني بقياده لطف براهم انذاك
والذي تقلد لاحقا منصب وزير الداخليه
لمناهله وغيرها بحسب الوثائق التي عرضها
التحقيق استخدم فيها ضباط في الحرس الوطني
عناصر اختراق للجماعات المسلحه جندوا
لتنفيذ هذه العمليات منهم ما يزال يعملون
واخرون اشتكوا تخلي هذا الجهاز عنه
التونسي يا زينب كشرود التي واجهت مصيرا
مريرا اعتقلها الامر الجزائري على الحدود
ولم تفلح رسائل استغاثتها من داخل السجن
للامن التونسي للتدخل بغيه الافراج عنها
بعدما كانت مجنده في مهمه اختراق باشراف
ضباط في جهاز الحرس الوطني ملفات امنيه
عالقه والشخصيات المتورطه فيها لم تطاولها
ايادي المحاسبه وهو ما يثير كثيرا من
التساؤلات حول منظومه امنيه وسياسيه عميقه
ما زالت تتحكم في المشهد التونسي رغم تقلب
وتبدل المسارات السياسيه
معنى من تونس كل من باحسن الاحياء الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي وصابر النفزاوي من نابل
الكاتب والمحلى السياسي ايضا اهلا بكما
ابدا بالسيد بلحسن اليحياوي ما الذي لفت
انتباهك فعلا في هذا التحقيق للجزيره
مع مواقف الحقيقه مع كامل احترامنا الجهود
التي بدلها القائمون او المنجزون في هذا
البرنامج الا ان كل ما روي تقريبا من خلال
هذا
للاسف توقفت الصوره اذا اطرح نفس السؤال
على السيد صابر النفزاوي في انتظار ان
يحلل الاشكان مع سيد بلحسن اليحياوي اتفضل
سيد النفزاوي
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اعتقد ان التقرير
الذي تفضلت به قد لا مساء الكثير من
الجواب مفصليه في قضيه الارهاب في القضيه
الامنيه في علاقه بالثوره التونسيه لكن
طبعا هناك بعض النقاط التي ربما تحتاج الى
بعض التنسيب في علاقه ان الاهاب ليس من
الف لهيئه مصطنعه لا نستطيع ان ننكر ان
هناك
لكن علينا ايضا ان نقرر في المقابل ان
الجزء الكبير من الارهاب هو الصناعه صناعه
الداخليه وخارجيه
يعني
ما الذي جعلك تقول ذلك
بالتحديد ارتباطا بالوثائقي
وربما من
يشاهد هذا الوثائقي قد يتبادر الى ذهنه ان
الارهاب هو مصطنع من الالف لكن حتى نكون
موضوعيين علينا ان لا نتعامل التطرف بتطرف
تهويلا او تهويلا يعني افرادا او تفريطا
القضيه الارهابيه هي الصناعه
ولكن صح التعبير بمعنى تغيير صناعه
الخارجيه غياب الافتعال غياب الاصطناعه
لكن هناك ايضا في المقابل هناك الصناع
هناك الجزء الكبير من عمليه الارهابيه
التي حدث في الثوره هي عمليه مصطنعه وطبعا
ليس غريبا ان تكون تونس البلد الاكثر
اختراقا والبنات الاكثر استهدافا بالارهاب
والاكثر تصديرا للجهاديين باعتبارها كانت
تعيش مخاط دوري مخاط ثوري ربما هو يعني
استثنائي طبعا في
المنطقه مسائله تاريخيه لم تحدث منذ ان
نهايه الاحتلال الفرنسي المباشر هذا هذه
الوضعيه الوضعيه الاستثنائيه وضعيه
المساهله التاريخيه
ما اسم اسميه جدل التاسيس جدل التاسيس هذا
خشيه تفضل نعم بعد اذنك اعود فقط للسيد
بلحسن اليحياوي معذره للانقطاع
وتستانف جوابك تفضل
من خلال هذا البرنامج حتى الوثائق التي
نشرت على اساس انها وثائق سريه هي كانت
وثائق صفحات الفيسبوك في تلك السنوات وما
حيك حول هذه الوثائق من الروايات ومن
سرديات هي ايضا قراناها اكثر من مره على
صفحات الفيسبوك ثمه امر مؤكد ان عمليه
الاختراع او اختراقات حتى اختلاف الجهاز
الامني الامني كان امرا موجودا في هذه
السنوات ولكن ثمه المسؤوليتين فيما يتعلق
بالتسفير وفيما يتعلق بالعمليات الارهابيه
وفيما يتعلق خاصه بالاختيالات السياسيه
ثمه المسؤوليه سياسيه هذه المسؤوليه
سياسيه يتحملها من كان يصنع القرار
السياسي انذاك وتمت المسؤوليه الجزائيه
وهذه المسؤوليه الجزائيه ليست شانا تونسيا
مخصوصا اتحدث خاصه عن عمليه التسيير
فعمليات تسفير الافراد او العامل الا
رهابي اذا ما سمي بؤر التوتر الى سوريا
الى العراق الى ليبيا تتداخل فيها الكثير
من الاجهزه اجهزه المخابرات الدوليه وتشرف
عليها ايضا حتى بعض الدول بعض الدول التي
دفعت الاموال وبعض الدول التي وصلت
المعلومات الامنيه وبعض الدول التي سهلت
عمليه التسيير وكان من الطبيعي ان يرتد
هذا العامل الارهابي الى الداخل لان
الارهاب له نفس تاثير انت تلقي به الى
الخارج ولكنه يرتد الى الداخل وعندما ارتد
الى الداخل اضر بالدوله التونسيه بما لا
مزيد عليه عندما نتحدث عن عمليه بارق او
نتحدث عن عمليه سوسه نحن لا نتحدث عن مجرد
جريمه ارهابيه حدثت بسبب تورط بعض العناصر
في الداخل او تغافل بعض العناصر في الداخل
او تهاون الامن التونسي نحن نتحدث عن
عمليه سببت انهيار الاقتصاد التونسي الذي
كان يعتمد في جزء كبير به على السيد
الاحياء قبل قليل قبل قليل اشار السيد
صابر النفزاوي الى ان
الارهاب في تونس جزء منه حقيقي وجوزها منه
صناعه
هل لفت انتباهك الشيء من هذا القبيل وانت
تتابع هذا الوثائقي
اعتقد اننا سوف نجرب في حق الضحايا الذين
ذهبوا الشهداء الذين دفعوا بارواحهم
ودماءهم في هذه العمليات الارهابيه حين
نقول ان هذه العمليه الارهابيه مفتعده كيف
نتحدث عن عمليات ارهابيه مفتعله ونحن
خسرنا خلال هذه العمليات افرادا من الجيش
الوطني وافرادا من قوات الامن والسياسيين
مرموقين ومواطنين عديدين سيمكن الحديث عن
استعاده ليست هناك اي دوله في العالم يمكن
ان تسمح لنفسها بقتل ابناء شعبها مهما
كانت هذه الدوله قميئه ومهما كانت هذه
الدوله رديئه ما حدث في تونس تقريبا كل
العمليات وانتم تحدثتم عن بعض العمليات
المخصوصه خاصه في تعليقات ما يتعلق بعمليه
ولكن هناك الكثير من العمليات هل ننسب
كثير فعلا كثير من العمليات يعني
عدم اصلاح المؤسسه الامنيه هو اكبر دليل
على ان لم تكن هناك ثوره في تونس ثوره
حقيقيه كانت مقدمه ثوريه كان مخاطا ثوريا
لكنه لم يكتمل نحن فشلنا في اخراج مقدمتنا
الثوريه من مربع الوجوه بالقوه الى حي
الزي الوجود بالفعل وبالتالي
بقيت في يد
من كل من يصل الى السلطه يحاول الموظف هذه
المؤسسه والمؤسسه وطبعا هذه النظره
التوظيفيه المؤسسه الامنيه تمنع اي رؤيه
اصلاحيه تمنع تنفيذ اي اي اجراء اصلاحي
بلاي عودا على كلام الاخ باحسن عندما يقول
انه الدول لا ترتكب بعمليات ارهابيه ضد
مواطنيه هذه قراءه مثاليه قراءه نبويه في
الح
قيقه والولايات المتحده الامريكيه منذ
السبعينيات ارتكبوا العديد من عمليه
الارهابيه داخل اوروبا باسم الشيوعيه
لتسويه الشيوعيه وفرنسا نحن نعلم
المخابرات الفرنسيه
في مواطنيها الفرنسيين في الجزائر وذلك
التشويه الاسلاميين في الجزائر وبالتالي
هذه القراءه غريبه في الحقيقه
الصناعه في تونس اصبحت موث اليوم انا في
هذا النطاق وفي هذا السياق اريد ان نكون
نقدم تحيه خاصه للاخ ماهر زين وهنا في
برلمانه 2019
لاسامته الكبيره والجذريه
والحقيقه الشجاعه في اللثام الكثير من
عمليه الارهابيه في تونس مثل
التي ثبت انها مفبركه لديه كتابه اره
اب عنوانه عمليه
كشف فيها كيف تورط لطف البراهم في هذه ما
كان امر الحرس الوطني في صناعه تلك
العمليه ولكن
كان الامر كذلك سيد النفزاوي يسمحلي اسال
السيد بلحسن اليحياوي انه سواء سيد لطفي
ابراهيم او غيره مما ورد اسماؤهم وردت
اسمائهم في التحقيق هؤلاء طلقاء لم لم
يحاسبوا الا يثير ذلك اشكال معين في وضع
الامن والسياسي في تونس
لا طبعا الوضع الامني خاصه فيما يتعلق
وكما تطرق الصديق لانه لم تحدث محاوله
فعليه لاصلاح الجهاز الامني حتى يواءم
حاله الانتقال الديمقراطي اولا في تونس
وحتى تمكينه من ادوات التي يمكن ان يشتغل
بها بفاعليه على العكس من ذلك وضعت محاوله
تطبيع هذا الجهاز الامني كما هناك هذه
الروايات او السرديات التي تتعلق بوزير
الداخليه الاسبق لطراهم وايضا هناك روايات
التي تتعلق بالجهاز السري لحركه النهضه او
الجهاز الخاص لحركه النهضه الذي اخترق
الداخليه واخترق مفاصل الامن التونسي
واصبح يطوع او يستعمل اله الامن التونسي
لخدمه اغراضه ولخدمه مصالحه بل وايضا
للتغطيه على المخالفات حتى نقول الجرائم
التي حدثت في تونس كل هذه السرديات هي
السرديات موجوده جزء منها لا يمكن ان
نتحدث عن عن زيت دون ان يكون هناك اصل دون
ان يكون هناك حقيقه في الاصل نعم هناك بعض
القضايا التي لا تزال الى اليوم غامضه
وهذه القضايا تهم تهم التونسيين باجماعهم
شكرا عندما نعود حتى ما قبل 2015 فيما
يتعلق بقضيه النيله الى اغتيال شكلي
بالعيد ولا اغتيال محمد البران ونجد ان
هناك وسائل
تحذر نعم شكرا جزيلا لك بالاحسن اليحياوي
شكرا جزيلا لك صابر النفزاوي
اكد المحامي سمير ديلو في تونس ما زلنا في
اتصالا مع الجزيره تمديد الاحتفاظ
بالموقوفين وتحقيق معهم في شبهات التامر
على امن الدوله لفتره ثانيه مدتها خمسه
ايام اضافيه من بينهم الناشط السياسي خيام
الترك والمحامي والناشط السياسي الازهر
العكرمي والقياديه السابق بحركه النهضه
عبد الحميد الجناصي ورجل الاعمال كمال
الطيف كان ديلو قد قال في وقت سابق انه تم
اعلام فرع تونس للمحامين باحاله عدد كبير
من المحامين الذين يترفعون في القضايا
السياسيه الى التحقيق وذلك على خلفيه شكوى
تقدمت بها احدى النقابات الامنيه خلال
عمليات ايقاف القيادي في حركه النهضه نور
الدين البحيري منذ عام وشهرين واكدت
المحاميه ايناس الحراث توجيها دعوات
للتحقيق مع 14 محاميا دون توضيح التهم
الموجه اليهم مشيره الى ان قاضي التحقيق
سيستمع اليهم على دفعات في مارس اذار
المقبل وتضم القائمه عددا من المحامين
المعارضين لما يصفونه بانقلاب الرئيس قيس
سعيد او ممن ينوبنا عن عدد من الشخصيات
المعارضه
وفي ابرز ردود الفعل الدوليه على حمله
الاعتقالات الاخيره في تونس اعرب مفوض
الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان
عن قلقه بشان حمله القمع المتزايده ضد
المعارضين السياسيين والمجتمع المدني في
تونس كما قال وطالب السلطات هناك باحترام
معايير الاجراءات القانونيه والمحاكمه
العادله والافراج الفوري عن جميع
المعتقلين تعسفيا اما المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه فقال ان بلاده قلقه من
التقارير التي تتحدث عن اعتقال شخصيات
سياسيه ورجال اعمال وصحافيين في تونس
واضاف برايس ان الولايات المتحده تحترم
تطلعات الشعب التونسي لنظام قضائي مستقل
وشفاف قادر على توفير الحريات للجميع من
جهتي قال المفوضه الاعلى لسياسه الخارجيه
والامن بالاتحاد الاوروبيه ان الشراكه مع
تونس متجذره في القيم المشتركه على غرار
الديمقراطيه ودوله القانون وحقوق الانسان
بما في ذلك الحريات الاساسيه مضيفا نعتقد
ان احترام الحق في محاكمه عادله
ومتطلبات الاجراءات القانونيه التي من
بينها شفافيه القضاء هي من الركائس
الاساسيه
لكن الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد ابدى رفضه
للانتقادات الدوليه وقال خلال لقائه
برئيسه الوزراء نجله بودن ان تونس ليست
تحت الاستعمار او الانتداب بل هي دوله
مستقله ذات سياده ونعلم جيدا كما قال ما
نقوم به في ظل احتراما شاملا للقانون
سيادتنا فوق كل اعتبار
وفكره الحريه
استبطناها قبلهم بكثير
فلينظر في تاريخهم قبل ان ينظروا في
تاريخنا
ولينظر في واقعهم قبل ان يتحدثوا عن
الاوضاع في تونس
لسنا تحت الاستعمار او الحمايه او
الانتداب نحن دوله مستقله
ذات سياده
ونعلم جيدا ما نقوم به في ظل احتراما كامل
للقانون
في غضون ذلك اصدرت اربعه احزاب سياسيه
تونسيه معارضه بيانا تعلن فيه دعمها
لتحركات الصحفيين ودانت احزاب التيار
والتكتل والكتب والعمال مسمتهم محاولاته
سلطه الانقلاب تدجين الاعلام كما نددت بما
وصفته تجويع الصحفيين وتحويل التلفزه
الوطنيه العموميه الى بوق رديء
للديكتاتوريه واعتبرت ذلك جزءا من تحكم
سلطه الانقلاب في ميثاق الحقوق والحريات
حسب وصفها
[موسيقى]
نجحت فرق الانقاذ التركيه في هاتاي في
انقاذ شخص على قيد الحياه من تحت الانقاذ
بعد مرور 200 و 278 ساعه من وقوع الزلزال
وشركت وسائل الاعلام التركيه لقطات من
لحظه انقاذ هركان ياسين البالغ من العمر
45 عاما من تحت حطام مبنى في منطقه دفنه
في هاتاي
معنى من غازي عنتاب مراسل الجزيره يونس
ايه ياسين يونس اهلا بك كيف هو المشهد
الان
مرحبا محمد المشهد هو انه بعد 12 يوما ما
تزال تركيا تحصي خسائرها نتيجه هذا
الزلزال هذه هي الحصيله حصيله القتلى التي
يزحف عدادها بشكل متسارع نحو حاجز
الاربعين الفا عدد المصابين يقترب ايضا من
110 الاف عدد المباني التي تهدمت او
انهارت بشكل كلي تجاوزت 350 الفا من اصل
اربعه ملايين مبنى في المناطق التي تضررت
جراء هذا الزلزال لكن محمد وسط هذه الصوره
القاتمه ما تزال تنبعث نقاط ضوء وهي هذا
الخبر الذي تفضلت بقراءته قبل قليل انه
بعد اليوم الثاني عشر ما تزال فرق الانقاذ
تنجح في انتشال يعني اعداد من الناجين فرق
الانقاذ ما تزال تتحدث عن عملها في اكثر
من 200 نقطه في الولايات ال 11 التي تضررت
من هذا الزلزال صحيح انه يعني هذه النقاط
سوف يتضاءى العددها بشكل متسارع خلال
الساعات والايام القليله المقبله لكن فرق
الانقاذ ما تزال تقول بانها متمسكه
باستنزاف كافه السبل والحيل من اجل الوصول
الى اكبر عدد من الناجين الذين ما تزال
تعتقد فرق الانقاذ انهم ما يزالون
يتواجدون في هذه المناطق حتى الان من اصل
11 ولايه التي تضررت بسبب الزلزال تم
الاعلان عن انتهاء اعمال البحث والانقاذ
في اربع ولايات لكن ولاياتان بالتحديد
ما تزال عمليات البحث فيها على اشدها
بالنظر الى تاخر عمليات البحث والانقاذ
بيوم او يومين بعد الزلزال مباشره تاخرت
فرق الانقاذ في الوصول الى هذه الولايات
وبالتالي وحجم الدمار ايضا في هذه
الولايات التي زرها يعني كبير جدا ما يعني
ان هناك احتمال اكبر لوجود ناجين في هذه
تحت ركام هذه المباني التي انهارت او
تصدعت وبالتالي عمليات الانقاذ سوف تتكثف
خلال الساعات والايام المقبله وان كانت
فرق الانقاذ تعترف بان احتمالات الوصول
الى ناجين بعد مرور هذه المده تتضاءل لكن
ايجاد ناجين بعد اليوم الثاني عشر تزيد من
امالهم وتدفعهم للمضي والمثابره في البحث
عن الناجين الان الاولويات بدات تتغير
بشكل تدريجي محمد صحيح انه هناك مازال
تركيز على عمليه انتشال والبحث عن ناجين
لكن اولويات اخرى بدات تفرض نفسها عمليه
التفتيش والبحث داخل المنازل في محاوله
لايواء مئات الالاف الذين ما يزالون في
الشوارع والذين يسكن بعضهم في هذه الخيانه
التي ترى خلفي
يعني بالاضافه ايضا الى توزيع وايصال
المساعدات الى المناطق النائيه زرنا احدى
هذه المناطق والقرى النائيه في محيط ولايه
ولايه
رصدنا بعض المشاكل والمعاناه التي عانتها
هذه القرى وعدنا بهذا التقرير محمد لنشاهد
[موسيقى]
قريه هادئه على اطراف مدينه انطاكيا روع
الزلزال سكونها
لم يبقي بيتا فيها دون ان يترك على واجهته
ندبه او يحطمه بشكل كامل
يتفقد صادق وصيره ما بقي من حطام منزلهما
تحت هذا الركام انتشل جثمان طفله لم تكمل
بعد ثلاث سنوات
لم نستيقظ بعد الهزه الاولى وفي الثانيه
ايقظني ابي واخذت ابنتي وبدات اركض علقنا
في السلم وبدا البيت يتداعى فوق رؤوسنا
فسقطنا الى اسفل البناء نجا الجميع
باستثناء ابنتي
[موسيقى]
فقدت القريه حوالي 30 من ابنائها في
الزلزال الحياه تكاد تتوقف فيها وباتت
تعتمد على المساعدات
اما اهلها فخسر كثير منهم ماشيته وما بقي
منها على قيد الحياه ينتظر الانتشار وفرق
الانقاذ لم تصل بعد
نصب يوسف هذه الخيمه في باحه منزله وفيها
يرعى والده المريض وامه التي اصيبت بكسر
في ذراعها اثناء هروبها من البيت خلال
الهزه الاولى
الى باقي يرم الا وصل حفيد لانقاذنا
وبعدها نظرت الى البيت وقد ذهب كل شيء لم
يبقى لنا شيء ضع كل ما نملك بعد اصابه
اتصلنا بالاسعاف انتظرنا وانتظرنا ولم
ياتي احد
في ساحه القريه يجتمع شيوخها يقول احدهم
انما حدث شبيه بيوم القيامه خلال سنوات
عمرهم الطويله يقولون انهم لم يروا شيئا
يشبهوا ما راوه يوم الزلزال
وحد الزلزال بين سكان المدينه وسكان
القريه في الخسائر الماديه والبشريه وان
كان وصول المساعدات وفرق الانقاذ الى مركز
ولايه هاتاي قد استغرق اياما فان وصولها
الى قراها اكثر تاخرا ويخشى سكان القرى
المتضرره من ان تتاخر كذلك عمليه اعاده
اعمار بيوتهم المدمره
من قريه طانيشما هاتاي
وفي محاولات اغاثه الناجين تحولت قاعده
انجرليك الجويه العسكريه شرقي اضنه تحولت
الى خليه نشطه لتوزيع المساعدات ونقلها
للمتضررين من الزلزال مراسلنا المعتز
بالله حسن رافق الجيش التركي على متن
طائره مروحيه لايصال المساعدات الى القرى
النائيه المتضرره من الزلزال في ولايه
هاتاي
المساعدات التي تم تجميعها في قاعده
العسكريه التركيه والموجهه الى المناطق
المنكوبه بالزلزال سيتم تحميلها على هذه
الطائرات المروحيه وهذه الطائرات هي جزء
من مجموعه اكبر من الطائرات تتوجه الى
المناطق المنكوبه البعيده والتي لا تستطيع
ربما الشاحنات الوصول اليها هذه الطائرات
تحلق بمعدل 60 الى 70 طلعه جويه وسطيا في
اليوم سنحاول ان نكون على متن واحده من
هذه الطائرات بعد قليل
تعتبر قائده انجرليك المركز الاساسي لنقل
المساعدات الى المناطق المتضرره جراء
الزلزال هذه المساعدات هي قادمه من دول
مختلفه وايضا هي مساعدات قادمه من المدن
التركيه غير المتضرره يتم تصنيف هذه
المساعدات وتنظيمها من قبل الجيش التركي
نحن هنا علمتني احدى المروحيات التي تنقل
المساعدات الى المناطق المنكوبه بالزلزال
هذه الطلعات الجويه يتم تنسيقها بين اداره
الطوارئ والطوارئ التركيه ووزاره الدفاع
التركيه يتم اختيار المناطق وفق حاجتها
القصوى يتم نقل ايضا المساعدات المختلفه
هذه المساعدات عباره عن خيم لوازم اطفال
وكل ما يمكن ان يحتاجه
المتضررون جراء زلزال سواء كان مواد طبيه
او مواد اضافيه كما ان هذه المروحيات لا
تنقل فقط المساعدات بل تنقل ايضا
طواقم المؤسسات الرسميه التي تحاول
الاعتناء بالمواطنين الذين تضرروا جراء
الزلزال
وصلنا الى هذه المنطقه في محافظه هاتاي
المروحيه ستنزل حمولتها هنا ومن ثم ستعود
الى قاعده في اضنه للتزود بمزيد من
المساعدات ونقلها الى مناطق منكوبه اخرى
المعتز بالله حسن الجزيره
[موسيقى]
وفي سوريا قالت وحده تنسيق الدعم التابعه
للائتلاف السوري المعارض ان اكثر من 55
الف شخص نزحوا الى الملاجئ بعد الزلزال
ليضافوا الى نحو 20,000 اخرين كانوا
يقيمون اصلا في الملاجئ قبل الزلزال وقد
تحول العديد من الساحات العامه وحقول
الزيتون في مناطق الشمال الى ما يشبه
الماوى المؤقت لعشرات الالاف من الاسر
التي سردها الزلزال هناك وتقول منظمات
دوليه ان توفير مياه الشرب وخدمات صرف صحي
اصبح امرا ضروريا لمنع انتشار الامراض
تنضم الينا من دمشق كورولا امينه المتحدثه
باسم مفوضيه الامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين
اهلا بك سيد امين تقديركم للموقف الان في
ضوئي ما شاهدتيه هناك
بصراحه يعني الوضع كارثي
وحزين جدا ومؤلم جدا لانه مع كل يوم يمر
حجم الخسائر يتكشف اكبر وهناك ادراك اكبر
بالاثر السيء جدا والمخيف الذي تركبوا هذا
الزلزال نحن كنا في حلب وكنا في اللاذقيه
وكنا في جبله ويمكن ان ترى انه رغم في هذه
المناطق ربما لا ترى بنايه مهدومه وعلى
الارض في كل شارع ولكن الاثر الذي خلفه
الزلزال على الناس فظيع هناك رعب هناك
صدمه لدى الجميع الاحتياجات كبيره
الاحتياجات الى الماوى الى الطعام الى
الشراب اذا الخدمات الطبيه الى توفير
ادواء السبل النظافه والخدمات الاساسيه
ولكن ايضا يمكن ان تشعر راس حالا باثر هذا
الزلزال على البعيد يعني لم اثره ليس فقط
بخساره بالارواح
وبالبيوت هناك تدمير ايضا للبنات التحتيه
لبعض المدارس
المستشفيات الطرق المصادر المياه النظيفه
اصبحت ايضا في خطر لذلك مساعده السوريين
سواء كانوا في ادلب او في حلب او في
اللاذقيه هو امر واجب ويجب ان يستمر ليس
فقط هذا الاسبوع والاسبوع القادم ولك على
مدى الاشهر القادمه وربما سنوات لمساعدتهم
على تخطي اثار هذا الزلزال انت تحدثيننا
من دمشق ونحن الصوره لدينا واضحه فيما
يتعلق فيما يجري في تركيا فيما يتعلق فيما
يجري في الشمال الغربي ولكن هذه المدن
التي اشرت اليها حلب اللاذقيه المناطق هذه
هل ترى وضعها يختلف بدرجه او باخرى عن
المناطق التي نعرفها في تركيا وفي شمال
غرب سوريا
يعني بصراحه ربما في هناك مثلا اليوم كنا
في قريه اسمها جبله
تمر في حارات او مناطق ربما لا ترى فيها
بيوت مهدومه ولكن في مناطق اخرى في نفس
القريه 24 بنايه اصبحت على الارض وكل
بنايه مكونه من ثمان تسع طوابق اكثر من
150 شخص قدو في هذه البنايات والمشكله انه
ليس فقط البنايات التي تدمرت هي التي شردت
العائله ولكن هناك بنايات كثيره ما تزال
واقفه ولكن الزلزال اضر فيها واصبحت غير
امنه وبالتالي العائلات كلها قد اخلت
واصبحت الان في الملاجئ في الجوامع عند
اقارب لها ولكن ربما اليوم لديهم سقف على
راسهم ولكن يحتاجون الى حلول طويله الامد
نحن ما زلنا في فصل الشتاء هناك برد شديد
ما زال هناك همم ارتدادات لهذا الزلزال
يعني يوم امس كنا نايمين بلا دقيقه
وحدث زلزال واهزت الوضع
الموجودين في الملاجئ في احد المدارس
ركضوا الى
الساحات الخارجيه وبقيوا طول الليل في هذه
الساحه في البرد لانهم خائفين يعني
واعانوا عندما حدث حدث الزلزال الكبير وهم
الان في حاله خوف وصدمه يخافون العوده من
بيوتهم ولكن ايضا
النكوف بهذه الملاجئ والجوامع ليس بالامر
السهل ابدا هناك اكتظاظ هناك حاجه لجميع
انواع الخدمات واعلى سبيل المثال المدارس
التي حولت الى
نسميها مقاول جماعيه هذا يعني ان هناك
تعطيل لعمليه التعليم ليس فقط لمن فقدوا
منازلهم او يخشون العوده الى منازلهم ولكن
حتى الذين بقيوا في منازلهم لان المدارس
تستخدم كمااون جماعيه
يعني نتائج هذا الزلزال وخيمه ويجب ان
يكون هناك تضافر للجهود لمساعده جميع من
تضرر
والمسارعه في هذه المساعده والالتزام في
التقديمها ليس فقط حين تكون الكاميرات
تنقل ما احدثه الزلزال من دمار ولكن حتى
عندما تنتقل الكاميرات الى ازمه اخرى في
العالم ان يبقى الالتزام بمساعده كل
السوريين الذين تضرروا موجود وقوي لانهم
فعلا بحاجه الى مساعده ماسه مروا 12 عام
من الازمه السوريه
واقتصاديه وهم الان لديهم كارثه اكبر يعني
فعلا عندما تتكلم مع هؤلاء مع هذه
العائلات هناك ليس فقط حزن هناك حزن هناك
صدمه هناك رعب هناك نوع من الاحساس الرغبه
شكرا لك رولا امين المتحدثه باسم مفوضيه
الامم المتحده للشؤون اللاجئين من دمشق
قد اتهم مدير الدفاع المدني السوري في
الشمال رائد الصالح اتهم وكالات الامم
المتحده بتسييس المساعدات عبر طلبها
الموافقه من نظام الاسد على فتح المعابر
مشيرا الى وجود سند قانوني يتيح للامم
المتحده تنفيذا العمليات عبر الحدود دون
الحاجه لتفويض من الدول او حتى من مجلس
الامن واضاف صالح ان وكالات الامم المتحده
وجه التهديدات للمنظمات الانسانيه السوريه
تطالبها بدور محدود وذلك لانزعاجها من
الاتهامات التي وجهتها لها منظمات انسانيه
عامله في سوريا بالتقصير في الاستجابه
للكارثه
لكن نائب المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم
المتحده فرحان حق النفا في مقابله مع
الجزيره الاتهامات التي وجهها الدفاع
المدني السوري في الشمال لوكالات الامم
المتحده بتسييس المساعدات عبر طلبها
الموافقه من نظام الاسد على فتح المعبر
هذه الاتهامات في الحقيقه زائفه تماما
الامم المتحده لها موقف قوي ضد تاسيس
الاغاثه الاغاثه بالنسبه لنا اولويه وهي
ان تصل الى كل من يحتاجها ايا كان مكانه
وعلى اي طرف او جهه من الحدود او اي جهه
من القتال ينتمي اليها واضح ان هذا
الزلزال تجاوز الحدود الوطنيه والحدود
السياسيه وترك الاف النازحين يعانون من
الحاجه الملحه للخدمات ونحن نريد ان نصل
اليهم جميعا لهذا السبب نحن ننشط سوريا
ونعمل من خلال ثلاثه معابر حدوديه ببساطه
فان غرضنا هو ان نصل الى اكبر عدد ممكن من
الناس ايا كانت خلفياتهم
وحول الاحتقان بين المنظمات المحليه
العامله في سوريا ووكالات الامم المتحده
قال فرحان حق ان المنظمه الدوليه تعمل
بشكل جيد مع كل المجموعات على الارض
ننوي بالتاكيد ان نعمل بشكل جيد مع كل
المجموعات على الارض وقد فعلنا ذلك طيله
فتره الحرب كما ننوي ان نقوم بذلك طيله
فتره اغاثه المنكوبين من الزلزال لكن في
نهايه المطاف علينا ان نضمن ان لا طرف من
هذه الاطراف سيستخدم هذه الاغاثه للحصول
على مكسب سياسيا على حساب طرف اخر فليس من
الانسانيه بمكان ان نستغل معاناه الناس
لتحقيق مكاسب سياسيه
[موسيقى]
طلب الرئيس الاوكراني الغرب بالاسراعي في
كل اشكال الدعم الموعوده لبلاده في حربها
مع روسيا محذرا من ان اوكرانيا قد لا تكون
المحطه الاخيره للرئيس بوتين جاء ذلك في
كلمه القاها
اعمال مؤتمر الامن بميونخ ويعقد هذا
المؤتمر قبل اسبوعا من مرور عام على حرب
روسيا في اوكرانيا وبحضور وفد امريكي كبير
هذا العام ابرز الملفات المطروحه للنقاش
الحرب الدائره وامن اوروبا اضافه الى
قضايا اخرى
مؤتمر الامن بميونخ في عام الحرب وقبل
اسبوع من الذكرى الاولى للصراع المسلح
الذي غير اوروبا والعالم بتدعيته السابقه
واللاحقه جدول اعمال مختلف وحضور ايضا
مختلف في غياب الضيف المعتاد وزير
الخارجيه
الوفد الامريكي المشارك هذه السنه لافته
جدا من حيث العدد والثقل وكثره الملفات
المطروحه حاليا
افتتحت اعمال المؤتمر بكلمه عن بعد للرئيس
الاوكراني
قال فيها ما سمع من قبل وكرر منى شدته
للتعجيل بجهود دعم الغرب لبلاده
نحتاج الى السرعه سرعه في ابرام اتفاقاتنا
سرعه في الامدادات لتعزيز معركتنا سرعه في
القرارات للحد من القدره الروسيه لا بديل
عن انتصار اوكرانيا لا بديل عن اوكرانيا
في الاتحاد الاوروبي وحلف شمال الاطلسي
حذر الحضور من ان بلا هولن تكون المحطه
الاخيره للرئيس بوتين الانشغال الكبير
للاوروبيين بحرب اوكرانيا لا يقلل بل على
العكسي يرفع درجه حراره النقاشات المتعلقه
بمستقبل القاره وامنها اكثر من اي وقت مضى
من بينها الى اي مدى ينبغي ان تعزز اوروبا
قدراتها العسكريه والى اي حد يمكنها
الاعتماد على الولايات المتحده في امنها
وكم ينبغي ان تنفق الحكومات على الدفاع
كلام المستشار الالماني
يصب في هذا الاتجاه شدد على ضروره بناء
القدرات الدفاعيه لاوروبا والنيتو وايضا
على الحذر من الانزلاق في الصراع الدائر
اقول للرئيس الروسي ليس اسلحتنا ما سيطيل
امد الحرب وانما متى ما فهم بوتين استحاله
تحقيق اهدافه فان نهايه الحرب ستكون اسرع
سنعمل على تحقيق التوازن بين د عم
اوكرانيا عسكريا وعدم اندلاع حرب بين
النيتو وروسيا
حرمته
روسيا مستفزه من انخراط الولايات المتحده
في الحرب لم يعد هناك شك صرحت المتحدثه
باسم الخارجيه وهي تصف تصريحات المستشاره
الامريكيه للشؤون السياسيه بالعبثيه
يمكننا الاستنتاج من جديد انخراط الولايات
المتحده في الصراع في اوكرانيا فهي تسلم
كم من كبيرا من السلاح والمعلومات
الاستخباراتيه وتشارك في التخطيط المباشر
للعمليات القتاليه
تقريبا بعد عام من حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا
لافقا لنهايه القتال ولا فرصه للانخراط في
مسار تفوضي قد يحدد جدولا زمنيا لتضع
الحرب اوزارها اخيرا كل الدعم الغربي غير
المسبوق لدوله واحده في مواجهه روسيا
والعقوبات الاقصى في التاريخ ضد موسكو لم
تغير الكثير في مشهد حرب مستمره ضحاياها
المباشرون وغير المباشرين كثر وبتداعيات
لحدود لها ثلاثه ايام هي مده مؤتمر ميونخ
للمفارقه انعقد العمل ماضي قبل ايام قليله
من حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا اما هذا العام
فالسياق صراع قلب الحسابات وبدل الاولويات
وغير تحالفات العالم المعلنه منها
والمستتره
معنى من موسكو عضو مجلس سدوم الروسي ومن
واشنطن روبرت هنتر السفير الامريكيه
السابق لدى النيتو وكبير الباحثين في مركز
العلاقات عبر الاطلسي اهلا بضيفينا نبدا
بالسيد فيدروف
الكل يتحدث عن روسيا في مؤتمر ميونخ
وروسيا غائب كيف تقبلت كل هذا الحديث عنها
في الواقع انه حديث
يعكس الازمه النفسيه ان بعض الامور تتطور
ان العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
وحديثهم عن انها غير قانونيه ان العمليه
العسكريه قانونيه تماما لان هذه المناطق
تابعه لروسيا لان انفصالها عن الاتحاد
السوفيتي كان غير قانوني حسب الدستور
السوفيتي الذي نقد في الواقع ليس هناك اي
وثائق قانونيه تؤكد انفصال اوكرانيا عن
الاتحاد السوفيتي لذلك هذه العمليه
العسكريه قانونيه تماما وعندما تقوم هذه
الدول برده فعل عدوانيه المانيا وفرنسا
تهدد روسيا وتمد مناطق واراضي اوكرانيا
تابعه لنا بالمتخصصين والمرتزقه ان هذا
عمل غير منطقي وعدواني لان في هذه المرحله
ممكن ان نقول انهم يتخطوا الخطوط الحمراء
وعندها سوف تدمر روسيا فرنسا والمانيا
فيزيائيا ولن تعودوا على وجه المعموره الا
يفهمون هذا ولكن
بالمقاطعه هنا هذه يعني هذه اللهجه التي
تتحدث بها انت الان
تعتبر العمليه قانونيه طبعا قانونيه من
وجهه نظر موسكو فقط ولكن هذا الحديث عن
تهديد فرنسا والمانيا
ومزحه من الخارطه تقريبا هذا هو مفهوم
كلامك اليس هذا هو الخطاب المخيف لروسيا
روسيا لان روسيا تدافع عن اراضيها وتقوم
بعملها عسكريه على اراضيها ومناطق تابعه
لها انظروا للخريطه نحن لن نجاح دوله
غريبه ان اوكرانيا دوله وجودها غير
قانونيه لقانونيه لذلك نحن نقوم بعمليه
على اراضي تابعه لنا ووجود قوات واسلحه
اجنبيه هذا تعدي على اراضينا وهذا نقد
للعقيده العسكريه
الروسيه ولدينا الحق ان ندمر جميع هذه
الدول المعاديه
ولذا هذه الدول لا يوجد اي قدرات عسكريه
ممكن ان تواجه بها روسيا لذلك
تعاملهم وتصوراتهم غبيه ان تصرفات المانيا
وفرنسا اعمالهم تهدد دولهم والسؤال الاهم
لماذا تريد المانيا ان تمد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه
وتهدد انها لماذا تقوم المانيا بتهديد
المواطنين الذي يتحدث به السيد بيدروف
نسال السيد روبرت هانتر هذا المنطق ربما
يعكس
عمق ما تفكر به القياده الروسيه هل سيسهم
ذلك في مزيد اصطفاف الولايات المتحده
والنيتو مع اوكرانيا في هذه الحرب
هذا المنطق الروسي الذي سمعناه توا هو شيء
جديد في الايام السابقه
ايام الاتحاد السوفيتي
وحتى علق العمل 2014
ثم وصلنا 2021 روسيا كانت تقبل باوكرانيا
على بانها دوله مستقله او منفصله
في عام 1975
اتحاد سوفيتي كان موجودا ولكن فيه كان
هناك تصريحه او اعلانه الذي
كتبت فيه ضمنت فيه وروسيا وامريكا ودوله
اوروبيه اخرى حدود اوكرانيا وحمايتها من
العدوان اذا روسيا في حاله انتهاك واضح
للاتفاقات السابقه رغم انهم يقولون عكس
ذلك الهدف الان هو ايجاد طريقه لايقاف هذه
الحرب وايقاف العدوان الروسي ضد اوكرانيا
ثم الجلوس للحديث عن كيفيه ان كان خلقه
علاقه بين اوكرانيا وروسيا
بتكون فيها المصالح الروسيه محميه
والمخاوف الناس الذين يعيشون في منطقه
القرم والدمباس
الذين يعطون اسم رؤوس او للتحدث اللغه
الروسيه يمكنني النوع من الحكم الذاتي هذا
سيكون ممكنا لكن ما يمكن ان طالبه ان
روسيا
تكذب حول اوكرانيا
جزء من روسيا وهذا اعاده لكتابه التاريخ
روسيا القديم لفتره 19 وحتى 2014
22 سنه
ان كان لديه موقف معاكس تماما للموقف اللي
سمعناه قبل قليل ولكن سيد هانتر هل المنطق
الغربي ايضا في في ازمه لان الحلف الاطلسي
يدعم اوكرانيا
الى حد الوصول على حافه المواجهه مع روسيا
ومع ذلك لا لا يريد ان يدخل هذه المواجهه
هذه الاشكاليه الى متى ستدوم
عام 1997 في
قمه برلين وانا كنت هناك
بنفسي كان هناك اتفاق بانه
هناك تاسيس لقائنا صداقات
ولكن ايضا كان هناك
تاكيد بان اوكرانيا
تتحمل الكثير من التعاون مع العلم
ان نذكر لا اسميه ستكون دوله لا تابعه
لروسيا ولا الى النيتو ولا ثم بعد بعد
سنوات من ذلك
في العقد الاول من
العقد من القرن الجديد تغير الموقف لاسباب
عديده ولكن الاتفاق الاساسي هو اتفاق
1994 فيه وذكرت والتي
الحكومه الروسيه وبريطانيا والامريكيه
وايضا فرنسا والصين وافقوا فيها على عدم
القيام باي عدوان ضد اوكرانيا ولكن ما
قامت به روسيا في 2014
في
شبه الجزيره القرن وايضا قبل سنه ضد
دوله اوكرانيا كلما ليس فقط غير قانونيه
بل حتى انه عمل غبي
بعد اذنك سيد هانتر يعني مما قيل هنا اسال
السيد فيدروب في موسكو مما قيل في مؤتمر
ميونخ ان اوكرانيا قد لا تكون الاخيره في
جدول روسيا العدواني كما يوصف هناك
كيف يمكن ان تقدم تطمينات خاصه وان خطابك
انت ايضا قبل قليل يغذي هذه المخاوف
انصتوا لي اي شخص لديه اي تعليم قانوني
عليه ان يؤكد موقفه اذا كنا نتحدث عن
القوانين الدوليه اذا الحديث عن القوانين
الدوليه بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه لم يكن هناك
اوكرانيا واما روسيا التي كانت تمثل
الاتحاد السوفيتي كان لها حدود معينه
واراضي معينه ونحن لدينا حق ان نحدد انظمه
الحياه على هذه المناطق واذا كانت هذه
المناطق تهدد
اراضينا وهي دول غير
ذات سياده اذا لدينا الحق ان ندافع عن
اراضينا وحدودنا ضد هذه المناطق نحن هو هو
هذا دائما هذا المنطق الذي تؤكده موسكو
باستمرار شكرا لك سيد بيدروف من موسكو
شكرا لك سيد هانتر من واشنطن
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن تغييرات في
قياده مختلف المناطق العسكريه دون توضيح
لاسباب هذه التغييرات
تغييرات في قياده مناطق عسكريه روسيه
مختلفه اعلنتها وزاره الدفاع شملت المناطق
العسكريه المركزيه والجنوبيه والغربيه
والشرقيه لم توضح الوزاره السبب فيما اذا
كان مرتبطا بما تسميه العمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا التفسير الاقرب حتى الان هو ما
اعلنته موسكو مطلع العام الحالي عن عزمها
اجراء تغييرات كبيره على قواتها المسلحه
بين عامي 2023
والفين وسته وعشرين
[موسيقى]
اما قياده القوات الروسيه المحاربه في
اوكرانيا فكانت شهدت تغييرات على مدار
العام الاول للحرب الشهر الماضي يعين
الجنرال
وهو قائد الاركان العامه للجيش الروسي
قائدا لما تسميه موسكو العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه وتعيينه جاء بعد ثلاثه اشهر من
تكليف سلفه الجنرال
بنفس المهمه
شهدت اروقه الاتحاد الافريقي قمما مصغره
لبحث تسويه الازمات والصراعات في القاره
تعتبر مبادره اسكات البنادق جزءا من 15
مشروعا رئيسيا في رؤيه افريقيا
قبل عشره عوام المبادره كان مقررا لها
تسويه جميع الصراعات بحلول 2020 قبل ان
تمدد حتى العام 2030
تضاءلت فرص العوده للديار فاستعراض
اللاجئون عن الخيام بالمساكن الخشبيه
يحتضن هذا المخيم الواقع غربي اثيوبيا
قرابه خمسين الفا من لاجئ جنوب السودان
بعضهم ولد وترعرع هنا هو احدى الصور
الماساويه لافرازات الحرب في القاره
وللحد من تبعات الحروب اطلق الاتحاد
الافريقي مبادره لاسكات البنادق وهي
مقاربه قاريه شامله لمنع النزاعات
وادارتها وتعزيز اليات المصالحه لجعل
افريقيا خاليه من اي حروب بحلول عام 2030
للتحقيق هذه المبادره الاتحاد الافريقي
كون منظومه للحكم الرشيد هذه المنظومه
تسعى الى تشجيع القاره او دول القاره
الافريقيه لتعزيز اسس الحكم الرشيد على
مستوى على المستوى المحلي والمستوى القومي
والمستوى القاري
تعد اتفاقيه السلام الاثيوبيه احدث
انجازات المبادره اذ وضعت وبجهود افريقيه
خالصه حدا للصراع الدام عامين في بلد
محوري بالقاره كاثيوبيا ورغم السلام
المحرز هنا ظلت ماكينه الحروب مستعره في
اماكن اخرى مضطر الاتحاد الافريقي الى
تمديد عامل المبادره التي كان مقررا وقف
العمل بها عام 2020 عشر سنوات اخرى سيصلك
اذا نظرنا الى خطه التنفيذ فانها تواجه
مشكلات في القضايا السياسيه والامنيه
والمبادره تتطلب استجابه كامله ومتعدده
الاطراف وتحتاج لدعم اوسع من الدول
الاعضاء والشركاء لكن التحدي الاكبر في
رايي يتعلق بمساله الحوكمه والحكم الرشيد
وانشاء حكومات قادره على تلبيه احتياجات
السكان
افريقيا باكثر من 14 نزاعا نشطا يتصدرها
الصراع مع جماعات التطرف العنيف كما يصفها
الاتحاد الافريقي والتي تشمل دولا
كالصومالي ومالي وموزمبيق ونيجيريا
وبوركينا فاسو والنيجر وتشهد القاره
الافريقيه صراعات ضد الحركات المتمرده او
الانفصاليه فيما تعد الصراعات العرقيه
احدى المعضلات الامنيه في كل من اثيوبيا
والسودان وجنوب السودان سبع سنوات تفصلنا
عن موعد الاتحاد الافريقي لانهاء الحروب
في القاره سقف زمني قد لا يكون واقعيا
مقارنه بحجم التعقيدات لكن المتفائلين
يشيرون الى ان ما تحقق من سلام رغم
التحديات يعد فرصه ينبغي البناء عليها
لتحقيق الهدف المنشود
حسن رزاق الجزيره اديس ابابا
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه اليكم
تذكيرا بابرز العناوين
برنامج الجزيره الاستقصائيه ما خفي اعظم
يعرض وثائق مسربه تكشف تورط قيادات امنيه
تونسيه في اداره عمليات مسلحه في البلاد
برلماني تونسي يؤكد ان القاده الامنيين لا
يزالون طلقات ويقدمون المشوره لفريق قيس
سعيد وتسجيلات صوتيه لنقابي امني مرتبط
بقضيه تسير المقاتلين للخارج المثاره ضد
معارضين ترصد حديثهم مع شخصيه تعمل لصالح
النظام السوري
بعد 12 يوما على الكارثه
فرق الانقاذ في تركيا تواصل العثور على
ناجين تحت الانقاد وعدد قتل الزلزال يقترب
من اربعين الفا جهود تتسارع لاغاثه مئات
الالاف من المنكوبين في مناطق تضررت
المباني فيها جزئيا او كليا
المشهد السوري في المناطق المنكوبه
بالزلزال تعثر ايواء المنكوبين وتقارير عن
نزوح اكثر من 55 الف شخص في شمال البلاد
وبعد حديثا عن تهديد وكالات امميه لمنظمات
انسانيه سوريه اتهمت الامم المتحده
بالتقصير نائب المتحدث باسم غوتيرش ينفي
للجزيره اي ضغوط ويقول ان الامم المتحده
تحرص على عدم توظيف اي طرف للمساعدات
حرب اوكرانيا تهيمن على مؤتمر ميونخ للامن
خوخ
للخلفاء ارسلوا دباباتكم لاوكرانيا
يقول ان الوقت الان ليس للحوار زينسكي يحث
قاده العالم على تسريع تسليم الدعم
العسكري وزير خارجيه استونيا يقول للجزيره
ان وجود قوات النيتو ضمانه في وجه موسكو
وروسيا تقول ان مشاركه دول النيتو في
الصراع بلغت مراحلها القصوى
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله مساءكم
كشف تحقيق لبرنامج ما خفي اعظم عن تورط
قاده وضباط في جهاز الحرس الوطني التونسي
في اداره عمليات مسلحه وقعت خلال السنوات
الاخيره في البلاد وخلفت ضحايا وشغلت
الراي العام التونسي عرض التحقيق على شاشه
الجزيره وثائقه مسربه تكشف تجنيد الامن
التونسي عناصر اختراق داخل الجماعات
المسلحه لتنفيذ هذه العمليات كما كشفت
تحقيق ادوارا لمنظومه امنيه وسياسيه ما
زالت تتحكم في المشهد التونسي بعيدا عن
المحاسبه
[موسيقى]
تونس الايادي الخفيه عنوان تحقيق ما خفي
اعظم الجديد فالبلد يعيش اليوم استقطابا
حادا على وقع اتهامات للرئيس التونسي قيس
سعيد بتوظيف القضاء لتصفيه حسابات سياسيه
مع معارضيه وفتح ملفات ضده كان ابرزها ملف
التسفير الذي يطااولت التحقيقات فيه
قيادات في المعارضه ونشطاء ورجال اعمال
لاتهامهم بتسهيل سفر شبان تونسيين لمناطق
التوتر في كل من سوريا وليبيا وغيرهما
احد الشهود الرئيسيين في هذه القضيه والذي
فتح له الهواء عبر وسائل اعلام محليه
وخارجيه هو عصام الدردوري
يعني ظن وجدلا في تونس رجل الامن ورئيس
منظمه الامن والمواطن عصام الدردوري حركه
النهضه ليست فقط سهلت عمليه تصوير الشباب
الى بؤر التوتر عرض تحقيق ما خفي اعظم
تسريبات تكشف ان الدردوري الشاهد في قضيه
التزفير متورط في تسفير وتسريب خطير هيا
من رجال المقاومه الاسلاميه في سوريا
تسجيلات صوتيه عرضها التحقيق كشفت مراسلات
بين عصام الدردوري وشخص لبناني يدعى محمد
علي اسماعيل يعمل لصالح النظام السوري
صديقنا اللي جلسنا معه في احدى المناسبات
ويعني المستشار الحكومي هو في ديوان
الطائره المدني والمطارات وعلاقات يعني
ممكن يوصلنا لشكون في هاي السياق تكشف
التسريبات انخراط الدردوري في تاجير
طائرات تونسيه بطرق غير رسميه والاخطر
وتسريب معلومات امنيه حساسه لمحمد علي
اسماعيل تتضمن صورا واسماء عناصر اختراق
جندها الامن التونسي خارج الحدود
بالنسبه للقرص المضغوط اللي فيه صور متاع
العناصر الغامقه بالاختراق في الوحدات
الامنيه اطلعت عليهم الصور كلهم موجودين
برجلين عندك والتسجيل شغال ماشي الدردوري
بدا انه اداه ضمن منظومه ارتبطت بملفات
عديده مثيره في تونس حيث برزت الرجل في
قضيه اتهامه بتجنيد فتاه لاسقاط قاض تونسي
ممن اشرفوا على التحقيق في احداث امنيه
مثيره اهمها حادثه المنيعله التي وقعت في
شهر مايو ايار عام 2016 وحصل ما خفي اعظم
على ملف وثائق التحقيق فيها فالعمليه التي
قدمت للمجتمع التونسي باعتبارها اكتشافا
لمجموعه من المسلحين المتطرفين واحباطا
لمساعيهم نحو تنفيذ عمليات مسلحه في
البلاد اسفرت عن قتل اثنين من المسلحين
واعتقال عدد اخر ومصادره اسلحه وذخائر حسب
الروايه الرسميه لكنها لم تكن في الحقيقه
بحسب الوثائق التحقيقات سوى عمليه مفبركه
بايدي قاده في جهاز الحرس الوطني بقياده
لطف براهم انذاك والذي تقلد لاحقا منصب
وزير الداخليه
وغيرها بحسب الوثائق التي عرضها التحقيق
استخدم فيها ضباط في الحرس الوطني عناصر
اختراق للجماعات المسلحه جندوا لتنفيذ هذه
العمليات منهم ما يزال يعملون واخرون
اشتكوا تخلي هذا الجهاز عنهم التونسي يا
زينب كشرود التي واجهت مصيرا مريرا
اعتقلها الامر الجزائري على الحدود ولم
تفلح رسائل استغاثتها من داخل السجن للامن
التونسي للتدخل بغيه الافراج عنها بعدما
كانت مجنده في مهمه اختراق باشراف ضباط في
جهاز الحرس الوطني ملفات امنيه عالقه
والشخصيات المتورطه فيها لم تطاولها ايادي
المحاسبه وهو ما يثير كثيرا من التساؤلات
حول منظومه امنيه وسياسيه عميقه ما زالت
تتح كم في المشهد التونسي رغم تقلب وتبدل
المسارات السياسيه
وفي الساعه الاولى من الحصاد قال الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي التونسي بالاحسان الاحياء
انه من غير الانصاف بحق الضحايا القول ان
العمليات التي قضوا فيها هؤلاء كانت
عمليات ارهابيه مفتعله وانه لا توجد دوله
تضحي بابنائها مهما كانت رديئه وفقه
تعبيره
اعتقد اننا سوف نجرب في حق الضحايا الذين
ذهبوا الشهداء الذين دفعوا بارواحهم
ودماءهم في هذه العمليات الارهابيه حين
نقول ان هذه العمليه الارهابيه مفتعده كيف
نتحدث عن عمليات ارهابيه مفتعله ونحن
خسرنا خلال هذه العمليات افرادا من الجيش
الوطني وافرادا من قوات الامن والسياسيين
برموقين ومواطنين لا يمكن الحديث عن
استعاده ليست هناك اي دوله في العالم يمكن
ان تسمح لنفسها بقتل ابناء شعبها مهما
كانت هذه الدوله قميئه ومهما كانت هذه
الدوله رديئه
اضاف كذلك انه لم تحدث محاولات لتطوير
الجهاز الامني في تونس بما يلائم حاله
الانتقال الديمقراطي في البلاد بل انه شهد
محاولات لتطويعه حسب تعبيره
قل لم تحدث محاوله فعليه لاصلاح الجهاز
الامني حتى يواءم حاله الانتقال
الديمقراطي اولا في تونس وحتى تمكينه من
ادوات التي يمكن ان يشتغل بها بفاعليه على
العكس من ذلك وضعت محاوله تطويع هذا
الجهاز الامني كما هناك هذه الروايات او
السرديات التي تتعلق بوزير الداخليه
الاسبقا وايضا هناك روايات التي تتعلق
بالجهاز السري لحركه النهضه او الجهاز
الخاص لحركه النهضه الذي اخترق الداخليه
واخترق مفاصل الامن التونسي واصبح يطوع او
يستعمل اله الامن التونسي لخدمه اغراضه
ولخدمه مصالحه بل وايضا للتغطيه
على بعض الجرائم التي حدثت في تونس
معنا من باريس سليم بن حمدان الدكتور في
القانون والمحامي في فرنسا اهلا وسهلا بك
سيدي حمدان بن حميدان
ما ابرز الملاحظات التي يمكن الخروج بها
من هذا الوثائق للجزيره
شكرا سيد محمد تحيه الى كل المشاهدين قناه
الجزيره في الحقيقه هذا الوثائق الليله هو
حدث مدوي حدث كبير جدا كثير من الحقائق
كانت لنا عليها قرائن وتاكد في هذا
الوثائق ان العمليات الارهابيه او اغلب
العمليات الارهابيه التي حدثت في تونس
كانت
احداثا موجهه عمليات موجهه
ساهم فيها
اطراف خارجيه تبين الطرف الخارجي الليله
بعلاقته ربما بمخابرات اجنبيه وبدول
اجنبيه
كذلك ظباط امن
ومسؤولون امنيون فاسدون لا زالوا يتمتعون
بكامل حريتهم وخارج دائره الملاحقات
القضائيه رغم قوه
قرائن الادانه
كذلك عناصر اختراق يتم تجنيدها خارج الاطر
القانونيه لان عمليات الاختراق هي في
الحقيقه عمليات منظمه ومؤثره بقانون
مكافحه الارهاب وغسل الاموال القانون
الاساسي عدد 26
لسنه 2015 سبعه اوت 2015 تحديدا فعناصر
الاختراق فيها قصر فيها يعني وتتم خارج
دائره القانون اعتقد ان وثائقي الليله اذا
لم يتم فتح تحقيق
حال وعاجل من طرف وكيل الجمهوريه بالمحكمه
الابتدائيه بتونس وهو المختص قانونا
باثاره الدعوه العموميه والتحريكها في هذه
الشبهات في ضد اشخاص معروفين دارت حولهم
قرء وذكرهم التقرير بالاسم مثل وزير
الداخليه لطفي براهم وهذا
السيد عصام الدردوري وغيرهم من المسؤولين
او هذا الشخصيه المسمى المدعو النمر خاصه
وان مسؤولا رفيع المستوى تحدث في هذا
التقرير واشار اليهم بالاسم
فان حاله السيد بن حميدان
اسف من من ممكن ان يحرك مثل هذه
القضايا او يدعو الى مثل هذه التحقيقات
وكيل الجمهوريه نفسه وكيل الجمهوريه لدى
المحكمه الابتدائيه هو المختص
بمقتضى قانون مكافحه الارهاب وغسل ومكافحه
غسل الاموال مختص باثاره هذه الدعوه
والتحريكها انا فقدت تسمح لي سيد محمد ان
اشير الى ان هذا الارهاب الذي هو تحت
الطلب مثل ما عنون به السيد نائب الشعب
ماهر زيد كتابه حول حادثه المنيه للمفبركه
هذا الارهاب كان ارهابا مقصودا في الحقيقه
انا كنت دائما صاحب هاشتاج الذي يقول بان
الانقلاب هو الارهاب نتحدث اليوم في تونس
عن انقلاب هيات له مناخات هذه العمليات
الارهابيه لوصف العشريه الديمقراطيه بانها
سوداء يعني هذا مقصود هاته المافيا او
هاته العصابه التي حركت هذه العمليات
الارهابيه وهي المسؤوله قتل ابنائنا عن
قتل جنودنا عن قتل ابنائنا من الامنيين
ولكن
ان مثل هذا القول وكانه تبرئه لاي طرف
يمكن ان يكون انخرط في ارهاب حقيقي
والصاق كل هذه التهم
باشياء سريه او اشياء مريبه قامت بها
اجهزه للدوله
هو بكل اكيد ان هناك ان الارهاب مدان وانه
نحن كنا من الذين قدموا هذا المشروع
لمكافحه الارهاب ولكن ما حدث وما كشف عنه
هذا التقرير تحديدا هي ان هذه الاجهزه
الامنيه كانت مخترقه وانها كانت تعمل خارج
دائره القانون لان حتى عمليه
تنظيم الاختراق للجماعات او العصابات
الارهابيه يجب ان تتم في اطار القانون ان
يكون هناك يعني اذن قضائي بالاختراق وينظم
بمده محدده اظن انها حسب مقتدى الفصل 41
من قانون مكافحه الارهاب اظن انها مده
محدده باربعه اشهر قابله ربما للتمديد وفي
اطار السريه هذه العمليات التي تمت حادثه
المنيه لتحديدا ثم عمليه اخرى اشار اليها
التقرير مثل حادثه باردو وغيرها كانت
وهاته الفتاه القاصر على ما ذكر التقرير
انه حتى القانون يمنع توظيف القصر في هذا
الامر يعني هاته العمليات التي تمت خارج
دائره القانون هي يمكن على اساس قانون
مكافحه الارهاب الحقت العناصر الامنيه
التي قامت بها واساسا وزير الداخليه وهذا
المدعو عصام الدردوري والمدعو النمر شكرا
لك سليمان بن حميدان من باريس
[موسيقى]
التحقيق سيستمع اليهم على دفعات في مارس
اذار المقبل وتضم القائمه عددا من
المحامين المعارضين بما يصفونه بانقلاب
الرئيس قيس سعيد او من ينوبون عن عدد من
الشخصيات المعارضه
وفي ابرز ردود الفعل الدوليه على حمله
الاعتقالات الاخيره في تونس اعرب مفوض
الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان بولكر تورك
عن قلقه بشان حمله القمع المتزايده ضد
المعارضين والسياسيين والمجتمع المدني في
تونس كما قال وطالب السلطات هناك باحترام
معايير الاجراءات القانونيه والمحاكمه
العادله والافراج الفوري عن جميع
المعتقلين تعسفيا اما المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه فقال ان بلاده قلقه من
التقارير التي تتحدث عن اعتقال الشخصيات
سياسيه ورجال اعمال وصحافيين في تونس
واضاف ان الولايات المتحده تحترم تطلعات
الشعب التونسي لنظام قضائي مستقل وشفاف
قادر على توفير الحريات للجميع من جهته
قال المفوض ذو الاعلى للسياسه الخارجيه
والامن بالاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل قال
ان الشراكه مع تونس متجذره في القيم
المشتركه على غرار الديمقراط يه ودوله
القانون وحقوق الانسان بما في ذلك الحريات
الاساسيه
واضاف نعتقد ان احترام الحق في محاكمه
عادله ومتطلبات الاجراءات القانونيه التي
من بينها شفافيه القضاء من الركائز
الاساسيه
لكن الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد ابدى ربه
للانتقادات الدوليه وقال خلال لقائي
برئيسه الوزراء نجلبودن ان تونس ليست تحت
الاستعمار او الانتداب بل هي دوله مستقله
ذات سياده ونعلم جيدا كما قال ما نقوم به
في ظل احتراما شاملا للقانون
سيادتنا فوق كل اعتبار
وفكره الحريه
اصطبطلناها قبلهم بكثير
فلينظر في تاريخهم قبل ان ينظروا في
تاريخنا ولينظر في واقعهم قبل ان يتحدثوا
عن الاوضاع في تونس
لسنا تحت الاستعمار او الحمايه او
الانتداب نحن دوله مستقله
ذات سياده
ونعلم جيدا ما نقوم به في ظل احتراما كامل
للقانون
قد دعت منظمه العفو الدوليه المعنيه بحقوق
الانسان الرئيسه التونسي قيس سعيد الى وقف
ما اسمته حمله مطارده خصومه السياسيين
واعتبرت المنظمه في بيان لها اعتقال
الاشخاص بناء على مزاعم غامضه بالتامر
يتعارض مع حقوق الانسان الاساسيه في حين
وصفت المديره الاقليميه للشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا في منظمه العفو الدوليه هبه
مرايف حمله الاعتقالات الاخيره في تونس
بانها محاوله متعمده لسحق المعارضه
ومنتقدي الرئيس وذكرت المنظمه في بيانها
ان السلطات تقاعست عن تقديم ادله عن
ارتكاب المعتقلين لمخالفات في وقت لا تزال
اسباب عدد من الاعتقالات الاخرى غير واضحه
ودعت العفو الدوليه السلطات التونسيه
للتركيز على ايجاد حلول لمساعده اولئك
الذين تضرروا بشده من تدهور الاقتصاد بدلا
من حملات مطارده السياسيين المعارضين
[موسيقى]
الى تركيا فقد نجحت فرق الانقاذ هناك في
هاتاي في انقاذ شخص على قيد الحياه من تحت
الانقاذ بعد مرور 2008 ساعه من وقوع
الزلزال وقد شاركت وسائل اعلاما تركيه
لقطات من لحظه انقاضها كان ياسين اوغلو
البالغ من العمر 45 عاما من تحت حطام مبنى
في منطقه دفن في هاتاي
ومعنا من مدينه هاتاي
بلير المتحدث باسم المؤسسه التركيه للبحث
والانقاذ اهلا وسهلا بك
سيدمير الان ما هي الاولويه بالنسبه لكم
في
وغيرها
هناك بصيص امل وامل ضعيف في العثور على
ناجين هو امر ممكن اذا ما كانوا فعلا
محظوظين بان يكونوا محصورين في اماكن
يمكنهم الحصول فيها على طعام لكن الاخذ
بعين الاعتبار بان هناك ثلوجا كانت تهطل
وجليد ربما يذوب بعضها ويصبحوا مياها تصل
اليهم عبر الشقوق في المبنى مما يضيف فسحه
امل قد تكون ضيقه لكنها موجوده عدا عن ذلك
وعدا عن مساله ان جين والذين قد يكون منهم
عدد محدود فعلا الاولويه هي توفير الطعام
والايواء
للناجين بسبب الازمه ازمه الزلزال والتي
فاقمتها البرد
القارص وايضا ما تم انقاذهم يجب ان نعنا
بهم والذين طبعا لم يكتب لهم الحياه يجب
ان يدفنوا بطريقه تحفظه كرامتهم ايضا فسحه
الامل التي اشرت اليها هل تجعل من عمليات
البحث الان او اي رفعه للالقات تتم بشكل
حذر للغايه
يوسف
الامر كذلك لانه حتى الان في المناطق التي
نشطت فيها فرق الانقاذ في الاسبوعين
الماضيين وفي المناطق التي استجبنا نحن
فيها الى جانب الطواقم المدنيه
والدوليه الاماكن التي استطعنا الوصول الى
اكملنا عمليات الانقاذ التحديات الباقيه
تعني انه اما ان الاماكن التي يعتقد ان
هناك اشخاص فيها تحت الانقاذ عميقه جدا او
احيانا بسبب الانهاك وبسبب نقص الطعام
والماء حتى لو كان احد تحت الانقاذ ربما
فرصته في النجاه تظالت كثيرا وايضا فرصتنا
نحن في العثور عليهم تبارك والسبب لانهم
ربما من ناحيه الوعي اقل وع يا واقل قدر
على ارسال الاشارات بالنسبه للاواء
والاعاشه للناجين هل تراها تسير بشكل مريح
الى حد ما
انمي
نزاعله ايه كارثه ايا كان البلد لابد وان
تكون هناك نواقص في العمل وهذه
الكارثه ليست مختلفه الحكومه بذلت قصاره
جهتها لتوفير اماكن لاواء الناجين في
مواقع مختلفه
والمواقع التي تم تحديدها حددت كاولويه
بناء على وجود السكان وموائمتها لوجودهم
لكن كما هو الحال في اي كارثه لا يمكن لنا
ان نقول ان كل عمليات الايواء وتوزيع
الطعام ستكون مثاليه طبعا هناك مواطن خلل
او نقص لكن ربما بعد الانتهاء من العمليات
الاساسيه يجب ان تكون العمليات عمليات ما
بعد الكارثه تحدد اولوياتها بشكل ملائم
ايضا شكرا جزيلا لك سيد بليد تشاديمينا
المتحدث باسم المؤسسه التركيه للبحث
والانقاذ من مدينه هاتايا التركيه
[موسيقى]
اما في سوريا فقالت وحده تنسيق الدعم
التابعه للاعتلاف السوري المعارض ان اكثر
من 55 الف شخص نزحوا للملاجئ بعد الزلزال
ليضافوا بذلك الى نحو 20 الفا اخرين كانوا
يقيمون في الملجا قبل الزلزال
وقد تحول العديد من الساحات العامه وحقول
الزيتون في مناطق الشمال الى ما يشبه
الماوى المؤقت لعشرات الالاف من الاسر
التي سردها الزلزال زلزال هناك وتقول
منظمات دوليه ان توفير مياه الشرب وخدمات
الصرف الصحي اصبح امرا ضروريا لمنع انتشار
الامراض هناك
من احد مراكز الايواء في عفرين في حلب
معنا مراسلنا او مرحوران عمر اهلا وسهلا
بك كيف يعيش الناس هناك
نعم ما زلنا في هذه الصاله الرياضيه التي
يتواجد فيها عشرات العائلات هنا في وسط
عفرين
ويعيشوا
سكان هذه المنطقه
ظروفا قاسيه لا سيما العائلات التي نزحت
جراء تدمر تدمير المباني جراء هذا الزلزال
او المباني المتصدعه حيث لا يتمكن من
العوده اليها هنا عشرات العائلات
في هذه الساعات خلدوا الى النوم خلال
الساعات الماضيه كنا نرصد
حركه هذه العائلات هم
ينامون ليلتهم لا يوجد هناك تجهيزات كافيه
لا يوجد تجهيزات مناسبه لتوفير الدفع
الراحه رصدنا معاناه كبيره حتى للاطفال
لكبار السن اطفال يعني كان من المفترض ان
يكونوا
يتوفر لهم الراحه الرفاهيه الا ان يعيشون
ظروف قاسيه في هذه الصاله وايضا في
المواقع الاخرى كنا نتنقل بين
المخيمات العشوائيه رصدنا ان الخيام حتى
توفر الخيام التي توفرت لا يوجد فيها شيء
من
التجهيزات لا يتوجد فيها مدافع مع حديث عن
حاجه المنطقه الى الاف المدافع في كل
الخيام هي بحاجه الى
المدافئ يعيشون معادله قاسيه جدا هم اما
ان يكونوا داخل الخيام وسط بروده بروده
الارض لا يوجد عوازل في الارض
واقمشه الخيام رقيقه لا تقيهم البرد فهم
يعيشون المعادله اي انهم بحاجه الى هذا
الدفء اي انه لا يستطيع ان يبقى داخل
خيمته تحت ظروف وبرد قاسي وايضا هو بحاجه
ان يبقى خارج هذه الخيمه ليتمكن من اشعال
نار توفر له شيء من الدفع هذه التفاصيل هي
تفاصيل قاسيه عيشناها مع شكرا من هم في
المخيمات هناك ايضا حاجه الى رعايه الطبيه
بالاضافه الى توفير الغذاء المنطقه بحاجه
الى
من تشرد من العائلات هم بحاجه الى يقارب
60 الف وجبات غذاء بشكل يومي حتى تؤمن لهم
نعم شكرا لك عمر حوراني من
حريفه حلب شكرا لك
الا ان نائب المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده فرحان حق نفى في مقابله مع
الجزيره هذه الاتهامات التي وجهها الدفاع
المدني السوري في الشمال لوكالات الامم
المتحده بتسييس المساعدات عبر طلب
الموافقه من نظام الاسد على فتح المعهبر
هذه الاتهامات في الحقيقه زائفه تماما
الامم المتحده لها موقف قوي ضد تاسيس
الاغاثه الاغاثه بنسبه لنا اولويه وهي ان
تصل الى كل من يحتاجها ايا كان مكانه وعلى
اي طرف او جهه من الحدود او اي جهه من
القتال ينتمي اليها واضح ان هذا الزلزال
تجاوز الحدود الوطنيه والحدود السياسيه
وترك الاف النازحين يعانون من الحاجه
الملحه للخدمات ونحن نريد ان نصل اليهم
جميعا لهذا السبب نحن ننشط في سوريا ونعمل
من خلال ثلاثه معابر حدوديه ببساطه فان
غرضنا هو ان نصل الى اكبر عدد ممكن من
الناس ايا كانت خلفياتهم
[موسيقى]
طلب الرئيس الاوكراني من الغرب الاستراحه
في كل اشكال الدعم الموعوده لبلاده في
حربها مع روسيا محذرا من ان اوكرانيا قد
لا تكون المحطه الاخيره للرئيس بوتين جاء
ذلك في كلمه القهازيلنسكي خلال افتتاح
اعمال مؤتمر الامن بميونخ يعقد هذا
المؤتمر قبل اسبوعا من مرور عام على حرب
روسيا في اوكرانيا وبحضور وفد امريكي كبير
هذا العام وابرزوا الملفات المطروحه
للنقاش الحرب الدائره وامنوا اوروبا اضافه
الى قضايا اخرى
مؤتمر الامن بميونخ في عام الحرب وقبل
اسبوعين من الذكرى الاولى للصراع المسلح
الذي غير اوروبا والعالم بتدعيته السابقه
واللاحقه جدول اعمال مختلف وحضور ايضا
مختلف في غياب الضيف المعتاد وزير
الخارجيه الروسي
الوفد الامريكي المشارك هذه السنه لافته
جدا من حيث العدد وثقل وكثره الملفات
المطروحه حاليا
افتتحت اعمال المؤتمر بكلمه عن بعد للرئيس
الاوكراني
قال فيها ما سمع من قبل وكرر منشدته
للتعجيل بجهود دعم الغرب لبلاده
نحتاج الى السرعه سرعه في ابرام اتفاقاتنا
سرعه في الامدادات لتعزيز معركتنا سرعه في
القرارات للحد من القدره الروسيه لا بديل
عن انتصار اوكرانيا لا بديل عن اوكرانيا
في الاتحاد الاوروبي وحلف شمال
حذر الحضور من ان بلاده لن تكون المحطه
الاخيره للرئيس بوتين الانشغال الكبير
للاوروبيين بحرب اوكرانيا لا يقلل بل على
العكس يرفع درجه حراره النقاشات المتعلقه
بمستقبل القاره وامنها اكثر من اي وقت مضى
من بينها الى اي مدى ينبغي ان تعزز اوروبا
قدراتها العسكريه والى اي حد يمكنها
الاعتماد على الولايات المتحده في امنها
وكم ينبغي ان تنفق الحكومات على الدفاع
كلام المستشار الالماني
يصب في هذا الاتجاه شدد على ضروره بناء
القدرات الدفاعيه لاوروبا والنيتو وايضا
على الحذر من الانزلاق في الصراع الدائر
اقول للرئيس الروسي ليس اسلحتنا ما سيطيل
امد الحرب وانما متى ما فهم بوتين استحاله
تحقيق اهدافه فان نهايه الحرب ستكون اسرع
سنعمل على تح قيق التوازن بين دعم
اوكرانيا عسكريا وعدم اندلاع حرب بين
النيتو وروسيا
حرمته
روسيا مستفزه من انخراط الولايات المتحده
في الحرب لم يعد هناك شك صرحت المتحدثه
باسم الخارجيه وهي تصف تصريحات المستشاره
الامريكيه للشؤون السياسيه بالعبثيه
يمكننا الاستنتاج من جديد انخراط الولايات
المتحده في الصراع في اوكرانيا فهي تسلم
كم من كبيرا من السلاح والمعلومات
الاستخباراتيه وتشارك في التخطيط المباشر
للعمليات القتاليه
تقريبا بعد عام من حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا
لافقا لنهايه القتال ولا فرصه للانخراط في
مسار تفوضي قد يحدد جدولا زمنيا لتضع
الحرب اوزارها اخيرا كل الدعم الغربي غير
المسبوق لدوله واحده في مواجهه روسيا
والعقوبات الاقصى في التاريخ ضد موسكو لم
تغير الكثير في مشهد حرب مستمره ضحاياها
المباشرون وغير المباشرين كثر وبتدعيات
لحدود لها ثلاثه ايام هي مده مؤتمر ميونخ
للمفارقه انعقد العمل ماضي قبل ايام قليله
من حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا اما هذا العام
فالسياق صراع قلب الحسابات وبدل الاولويات
وغير تحالفات العالم المعلنه منها
والمستتره
من جنابه العقيد الكسندر رئيس تحرير
المجله العسكريه
السويسريه اهلا وسهلا بك
هل نلمس في مؤتمر ميونخ اوروبا قلقه على
مستقبلها
لست متاكدا من يمكن ان نقول انه اوروبا
متحده حول موقف واحد فيما يتعلق بتطورات
المستقبل ولا حتى حول حرب اوكرانيا فهناك
الكثير من المواقف والتباينه لكن بالنسبه
للسياسه الامنيه الاوروبيه تحديدا حدثت
عده تغيرات منذ بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا ما
ابرزها
بالنسبه للسياسه الامنيه وبعد ان سقوط
جدار برلين التصور كان بان اي تاثير عسكري
يكون في اوروبا كان بعيدا جدا عن الواقع
وان ثمار السلام بادت باتت محسوسه وفي
متناول الان نرى اذا ما لقينا نظره على
القاره الاوروبيه نرى ان هناك واقع قد
تغير وهذا الواقع بتغييره هذا وفيما يتعلق
بالسياسات الدفاعيه
واستراتيجيات الدفاع الاوروبيه ايضا تغيرت
بفعل ما حدث مع ذلك نرى اوروبا موحده في
دعمها لاوكرانيا ولكن اوروبا ما زالت في
حاجه
الى دعمها من قبل الولايات المتحده
نعم هذا صحيح
وهناك اسباب مختلفه لذلك احدها بالطبع هو
انتهاء الحرب العالميه الثانيه طبعا الامر
لم يكن خطا من جانب المتحده ان هذا
الاعتماد الامني والعسكري من الاوروبي
عليها موجود لكن طبعا معظمه يعود الى كسل
الاوروبيين انفسهم
والتفاؤل المفرط فيما يتعلق بسياستهم
الامنيه في اوروبا على مدى الثلاثين عاما
الماضيه عندما يقول للرئيس الاوكراني
زيلينسكي بان اوكرانيا لن تكون المحطه
الاخيره في حسابات بوتين هل هذا يغذي
المخاوف الاوروبيه اكثر واكثر
نعم ومنذ الفائن عندما اصبح اولادي مبسوط
رئيسا للاتحاد الروسي بدا فورا بنشر قوات
النوويه في
كانت هذه اشارات والان وبعد عده حروب
وازمات بدات بها روسيا هناك تصور بوجود
تهديد كبير في كثير من البلدان الاوروبيه
الشرقيه
البلدان الاوروبيه الغربيه
تراجعت امام التهديدات الروسيه في الماضي
لكنها الان تفهم انه امر يجب ان تتعامل
معه في العقود القادمه شكرا جزيلا لك
العقيده الكسندر بوتر من جنيف
ميدانيا قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
فريقا من المدربين الايرانيين وصل مؤخرا
الى لوجانسي لتدريب الجيش الروسي على
استخدام منظومات جويه هجوميه بدون طيار
وكانت وكيله وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
للشؤون السياسيه فيكتوريا نولاند قد تحدثت
عن وجود قاعده في القرن لاطلاق المسيرات
التي قدمها الايرانيون الى موسكو
منذ اشهر تتبادل كييف وحلفائها مع طهران
الاتهامات والنفية حول تزويد روسيا
بمسيارات ايرانيه قتاليه تستخدمها في
الحرب احدث فصول ذلك الجدل ما اعلنته هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه بشان الوصول فريق اخر
من المدربين الايرانيين الى لوغانسك
لتدريب الجيش الروسي على استخدام مسيرات
هجوميه حديث تزامن مع تصريح من الخارجيه
الامريكيه عن قاعده في القرم لاطلاق
مسيرات ايرانيه من قبل روسيا في سبتمبر
الماضي كان اول اعلان اوكراني عن اسقاط
مسيره ايرانيه اطلقتها ومنذ ذلك الحين
تقول كيف انها اسقطت 80% من جميع المسيرات
الموجهه ضدها متهمه موسكو باستخدام تلك
المسيرات في ضرب منشات البنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه
ابرز المسيرات الايرانيه شاهد 136 التي
يتراوح سعرها بين 20 الى 50 الف دولار
وتزن 200 كلغ هناك ايضا المسيره مهاجر سته
القادره على التحليق اثنتي عشره ساعه
والبالغ مداها الفيلم
الموقف الايراني من الاتهامات الاوكرانيه
الغربيه لم يكن قاطعا نفي رسميا تقول
طهران انها بالفعل زودت موسكو بمسيارات
ولكن قبل الحرب في الوقت نفسه قال القيادي
السابق بالحرس الثوري حسين كنعان مقدم
لموقع الجزيره نت ان بلاده تنتج المسيرات
لتقليص الاعتماد على النفط ولا تهتم
بالمواقف الغربيه لكن في الثامن من فبراير
الجاري نسبت وكاله ايرنا للانباء لمستشار
بارز لوزير الاستخبارات الايرانيه دون ان
تسميه القول ان المسيرات الايرانيه تقوم
بدور حاسم في الحرب بين روسيا والغرب
لاوكرانيا بالمقابل رصيد من المسيرات
القتاليه ابرزها برقدار تي بي اثنان
التركيه القابله للتزويد بقنابل موجهه
بالليزر والقادره على التحليق بارتفاع
سبعه الاف متر بمدى يبلغ 300 كيلو متر
وبسرعه قصوى تبلغ 220 كيلومترا في الساعه
وكانت الولايات المتحده قد اعلنت تزويد
اوكرانيا بمسيارات اشهرها من طراز سويتش
بليد 600 الانتحاريه التي تزن نحو 22 كيلو
جراما ويمكنها التحليق اربعين دقيقه بمدن
يتجاوز اربعين كيلومترا وبسرعه تزيد على
100 كم في الساعه ومع ذلك يتصاعد انزعاج
حلفاء اوكرانيا من المسيرات التي تطلقها
روسيا وتتهم ايران بتوريدها كان احدث
الداخلين على الخط وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي الذي زار كييف الخميس واتفق مع
زلينسكي على العمل المشترك ضد ايران في
المحافل الدوليه
قال مصدر دفاعي اقليمي ان سفينه واحده على
الاقل تملكها اسرائيل تعرضت لهجوما في بحر
العرب يوم العاشر من فبراير شباط الحالي
وقالت شركه الامن البحريه البريطانيه
او نعم ان ثلاثه سفن تعرضت للهجوم بواسطه
انظمه جويه مسيره في بحر العرب وقدرت ان
طهران هي من شن ذلك الهجوم
وجه 30 نائبا في مجلس العموم البريطاني
خطابا الى رئيس الحكومه
يطالبونه فيه بتوضيح جهود حكومته لحث
البحرين على الافراج عن جميع السجناء
السياسيين في البلاد بمن فيهم زعماء
المعارضه البحرينيه والمدافعون عن حقوق
الانسان والمحكوم عليهم بالاعدام بعد
محاكمات شابتها اتهامات بالتعذيب ونشر
النائب الاستر كارميل على حسابه في تويتر
نسخه من الخطاب الذي جاء في الذكرى الثاني
عشر لما سموها المظاهرات المطالبه
بالديمقراطيه في البحرين عام 2011
واعرب النواب البريطانيون عن قلقهم الشديد
مما وصفوها بحاله القمع المستمر في
البحرين مشرين الى ان هناك اكثر من الف
معتقل سياسي دون ذنب في المملكه كثير منهم
تعرضوا للاهمال الطبي واساءه المعامله
والتمييز
[موسيقى]
شهدت اروقه الاتحاد الافريقي قمما مصغره
لبحث تسويه الازمات والصراعات في القاره
وتعتبر مبادره اسكات البنادق جزءا من 15
مشروعا رئيسيا في رؤيه افريقيا
قبل عشره اعوام المبادره كان مقررا لها
تسويه جميع الصراعات بحلول 2020 قبل ان
تمدد حتى العام 2030
تضاءلت فرص العوده للديار فاستعراض
اللاجئون عن الخيام بالمساكن الخشبيه
يحتضن هذا المخيم الواقع غربي اثيوبيا
قرابه خمسين الفا من لاجئ جنوب السودان
بعضهم ولد وترعرع هنا هو احدى الصور
الماساويه لافرازات الحرب في القاره
وللحد من تبعات الحروب اطلق الاتحاد
الافريقي مبادره لاسكات البنادق وهي
مقاربه قاريه شامله لمنع النزاعات
وادارتها وتعزيز اليات المصالحه لجعل
افريقيا خاليه من اي حروب بحلول عام 2030
لتحقيق هذه المبادره الاتحاد الافريقي كون
منظومه للحكم الرشيد هذه المنظومه تسعى
الى تشجيع القاره او دول القاره الافريقيه
لتعزيز اسس الحكم الرشيد على مستوى على
المستوى المحلي والمستوى القومي والمستوى
القاري
تعد اتفاقيه السلام الاثيوبيه احدث
انجازات المبادره اذ وضعت وبجهود افريقيه
خالصه حدا للصراع الدام عامين في بلد
محوري بالقاره كاثيوبيا ورغم السلام
المحرز هنا ظلت ماكينه الحروب مستعره في
اماكن اخرى مضطر الاتحاد الافريقي الى
تمديد عامل المبادره التي كان مقررا وقف
العمل بها عام 2020 عشر سنوات اخرى
اذا نظرنا الى خطه التنفيذ فانها تواجه
مشكلات في القضايا السياسيه والامنيه
والمبادره تتطلب استجابه كامله ومتعدده
الاطراف وتحتاج لدعم اوسع من الدول
الاعضاء والشركاء لكن التحدي الاكبر في
رايي يتعلق بمساله الحوكمه والحكم الرشيد
وانشاء حكومات قادره على تلبيه احتياجات
السكان
افريقيا باكثر من 14 نزاعا نشطا يتصدرها
الصراع مع جماعات التطرف العنيف كما يصفها
الاتحاد الافريقي والتي تشمل دولا
كالصومالي ومالي وموزمبيق ونيجيريا
وبوركينا فاسو والنيجر وتشهد القاره
الافريقيه صراعات ضد الحركات المتمرده او
الانفصاليه فيما تعد الصراعات العرقيه
احدى المعضلات الامنيه في كل من اثيوبيا
والسودان وجنوب السودان سبع سنوات تفصلنا
عن موعد الاتحاد الافريقي لانهاء الحروب
في القاره سقف زمني قد لا يكون واقعيا
مقارنه بحجم التعقيدات لكن المتفائلين
يشيرون الى ان ما تحقق من سلام رغم
التحديات يعد فرصه ينبغي البناء عليها
لتحقيق الهدف المنشود
حسن رزاق الجزيره اديس ابابا
[موسيقى]
وعشيه قمه جديده اذا للاتحاد الافريقي في
اديس ابابا تطارد الانقلابات العسكريه
قاده الاتحاد ومؤسساته في نهايه سبتمبر
ايلول الماضي وبعد ثمانيه اشهر فقط من
دوره الاتحاد الافريقي السابقه اطاح
انقلاب في بوركينا فاسو بالنظام القائم
والثاني في البلاد خلال العام الماضي قبل
انقلابي بوركينا فاسو وتحديدا في سبتمبر
ايلول عام 2021 اطاح انقلاب عسكري في
غينيا بالرئيس الفاكوندي وقبله في اغسطس
اب عام 2020 اطاح انقلاب في مالي برئيس
البلاد المنتخب ابراهيم ابو بكر كيتا وبعد
اقل من عام على ذلك وتحديدا في مايو ايار
عام 2021 اطاح انقلاب جديد بالعقيد السابق
بانداو الذي نصبه قاده الانقلاب رئيسا
وهكذا تظل ظاهره الانقلابات والتي تجاوز
عددها 200 خلال السنوات الستين الماضيه
ونجح معظمها في السيطره على مقاليد الحكم
تظل هاجسا لكل القمم الافريقيه
وتمثل الصراعات المسلحه في افريقيا كذلك
هاجسا رئيسيا اخر للاتحاد الافريقي ورغم
عدم وجود احصاءات دقيقه يشار الى ان اكثر
من خمسه عشره دوله افريقيه تعاني من
نزاعات المسلحه من اشهرها من اشهرها
الصراع الذي يدور في اثيوبيا مقر الاتحاد
الافريقي بين الحكومه وجبهه التحرير
تيجراي
وليس بعيدا عن اثيوبيا وهذه المره في
الصومال يستمر الصراع المسلح بين قوات
الحكومه وحركه الشباب ومناصرها
في ليبيا دخل الصراع المسلح عامه التاسع
مع فشل كل الجهود الدوليه والافريقيه في
الوصول لمعادله السلام هذا طبعا فضلا عن
النزاعات المسلحه التي تحصد ارواح المئات
في نيجيريا والكونغو الديمقراطيه ومالي
والكاميرون وافريقيا الوسطى وغيرها وولد
فشلوا الحكومات والاتحاد في احتواء هذه
النزاعات في بعض الدول حركات للدفاع عن
النفس لتشكل بدورها هاجسا جديدا
ينضم الينا من جوهانسبورغ نعيم زينه
الخبير في الشؤون الافريقيه اهلا وسهلا بك
الى متى ستظل القاره الافريقيه على هذا
الحال
مررنا حقيقه قبل اكثر من عقد عندما تراجع
عدد الانقلابات بحيث اصبحت قريبا من الصفر
والشعار الطاغي كان التحول الديمقراطي لكن
على مدى العامين تقريبا من 2021
تغيرت الصوره تماما راينا اكثر من عشره
انقلابات بما في ذلك الانقلاب في تونس
ايضا الى اي مدى سيستمر هذا الوضع واحده
من العوامل وراء ذلك
وان الاتحاد الافريقي غير قادر او ربما
غير راغب في التدخل في القضايا الداخليه
للبلدان في الماضيه اقوى صغيرها من
المنظمات الاقليميه كانت تفعل ذلك وهي
ايضا تراجعت قدراتها اما فيما يتعلق
بعمليات حفظ السلام
في الماضي كانت تمويلات من الخارج وهذا
تراجع كثيرا
والاتحاد الافريقي الذي كان ينفق الكثير
من المال على حفظ السلام حول انفاقها الى
اوكرانيا اذا نرى ان بعض البلدان او اكثر
بلدان حقيقه تعاني من هذه الازمات كلها في
ان واحد هل التنافس الدولي روسيا الصين
اوروبا الولايات المتحده على افريقيا يؤجج
هذه الصراعات والانقلابات
القوى الاجنبيه بالتاكيد الفاقم الاوضاع
وعدد من الانقلابات في غرب افريقيا اذا ما
فحصناها بدقه نرى ان الضباط الذين
انفذوا الانقلابات كانوا متدربين في
الولايات المتحده
وعندما ايضا نراجع الدور الفرنسي الذي كان
مدمرا في البلدان الناطقه بالفرنسيه
الصوت يتقطع من المصدر روسيا اللاعب
الجديد يضاف الى هذه القائمه من التدخلات
ودورها يبدو مضادا للدوله الامريكي
والدوله الفرنسي من ناحيه هناك خوف لدى
كثيرين بان افريقيا ستصبح مره اخرى ميدانا
للحروب بالوكاله خاصه في المواجهه التي
تتم في اوكرانيا بين روسيا وح لف الناتو
بان ينعكس ذلك على القاره الافريقيه اذا
هناك مخاوف حول دور القوى الاجنبيه
هل منسب من سبيل لتهدئه مثل هذه الامور
ولو تدريجيا في الفتره المقبله
لو ان الاتحاد الافريقي كان قادرا او كان
عازما على اتخاذ مواقف اكثر قوه
وصلابه من حيث التدخل بشكل مباشر لان اسوا
ما يفعله الاتحاد الافريقي وما رايناه حتى
الان وحتى قبل عشر سنوات مع الانقلاب في
مصر ان الصوت يتقطع من المصدر
وعاده
شكرا للامور لا تدوم كثيرا شكرا شكرا
جزيلا لك نعيم جينا من جهان سب
ورت
[موسيقى]
كم هي صغيره
وغض وضعيفه اسد الصبيا وكبار السن وهي
تستخرج من تحت اطنان من الركام او يستعصى
رفع الاثقال عنها حتى الان او مجرد التعرف
على مواقعه ربما تقضي العائله كلها فلا
احد يتفقد الاخر والجيران ايضا في همومهم
منهمكون من يرعون لمد يد العون لا يعرفون
بالضروره من يبحثون عنهم وهل هم رقود ام
ايقاظ احياء اموات
يتحسسون بحثا عن الانسان اي انسان ففي مثل
هذه الظروف
تتلاشى الحدود
تذوب الانتماءات ويبقى الجوهر يبقى
الانسان مجهول المصير تحت الانقاد او
المصدوم والمبتلى فوق ارض سجلت زلزالها
قلوبنا مع هؤلاء جميعا نواسي ذوي الضحايا
نترحم على الاموات
ونرجو الشفاء العاجل للمصابين ونشد
بالخصوص الان على ايدي فرق الانقاذ نتمنى
لكم ليله سعيده